we are very excited because dave's
dave's hot chicken is now here in las
vegas sarah and fort apache they're a
southern california
tradition they have their new location
grand opening today here in las vegas i
ted just got in so i dragged him in here
because they sent some food dragged me
in
we're gonna do a little taste testing
can you handle spicy food but here's the
deal i can't but that says
reaper yeah yeah this is reaper you have
to sign a waiver before you eat this you
want
to try the reaper you realize i got to
do ninth island yeah
the four o'clock the five and the six
after the reaper
uh i'm done after this so this is all
you all right here we go how are we
going to do this
reaper can i can i get like a corner
like yeah a little
little look look just a little this is
like the hottest thing they have i know
i'm going to try i'm actually scared i
really am scared let me
okay you ready 30 seconds it's good
that's it
you have to sign a waiver that's how hot
it is you you took a bite of that yeah
you bite
the hot is hot how's the reaper it's not
bad
right that's like why does it give that
little oh
okay where's our water we don't have
water we don't have water
look what they gave us look oh this is
kidding me we've got no water so did
anyone want to try the reaper
maria the hot is the
hot is delicious okay i'm glad they're
here
but yeah i think we should sign two
waivers for the reaper i smell that
one's really hot
i just know we gotta toss it to break it
we need to get some water because we
don't have any water here
las vegas now we'll be right back